hey guys this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so for those who are
watching my video for the first time let
me quickly introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trainer for the past six years in hong
kong
and i've decided to make some youtube
videos together with my daily job
to actually show you what i'm doing at
work how i use
technical analysis to set up my trades
and to make money
so if you're interested about all the
stuff you guys are in the right place
so in today's video i want to make an
update on gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so gamestop video the last
time
i did was around here guys just below
this breakout so let me go
through this with you again it's
important guys to you know
do some what we call back trading so
here it's not really about training
because i gave you
some signals and they were actually
correct and it's interesting to
just look at it again and understand if
you are wrong
why and if you were right why as well
and how it played out
so here the first thing i did if you
guys remember so let me go on the first
time frame
so the first thing i did was to identify
the waves so that's why i use idiot
waves counting
to tell me where are my waves and here
abc
i was in a second wave of a larger
degree wave counting
and so i was expecting this abc to be
complete and to be broken on the upside
so i was
connecting the highs between here and
here
to get this trend line and you can guys
go
and check my videos i told you that as
long
as we trade below this trend line we are
bearish and whenever we're gonna break
it
we're gonna have some strong moves up
okay
this is what happened now what i'm
usually telling you guys i'm telling you
don't buy the breakout
buy the retest this is for me a very
good
way of training but it's not working all
the time
here if you do this on a far less time
frame you don't see the retest
so i don't think we're gonna see it i
think now the price action is too high
and we have different supports
so we're gonna go on the shorter time
frame to actually spot
if we could buy the re-test of this
breakout and you can see so this is our
breakout
trendline and we actually broke it here
around 163
and did it work on a 15 minute time
frame
yes 30 minutes okay
and up to the 30 minutes time frame you
could have both the re-tests here so
here we are breaking out you can see
this is our trend line
here we are breaking out up to 172.
so breakout confirmed this one you don't
buy it you wait
because you don't have the confirmation
this one is the confirmation level so
now you need to buy
but you don't buy here it's too high you
buy at the breakup level so you wait for
re-test which would have happened here
at 162.
so if your buying order was above 162
you would have been executed if it was
below you wouldn't have
been executed you would have missed this
trade so
buying the retests is a bit risky
compared to by the breakout
if you absolutely want to be in the
trade but this
is something guys i'm doing for a long
time and i can tell you that
the bad situation missing a trade is
fine you're going to go to the next one
but getting hammered when you go to the
wrong level and you don't have the stop
loss at the right place this is
something that can cost you a lot
financially and psychologically because
when you do a bad trend and you know
that you shouldn't have done it
this usually can bring you in a kind of
spiral
where you're doing bad decisions so if i
can share my experience with you here
very similarly i'm telling you don't buy
breakouts
only by re-tests and here on the
30-minute time frame it would have
worked
so from then we are bullish guys we are
bullish
of course and let's see what is gonna
happen
next we are done with this correction we
are doing here one two and we are in the
third wave
of this uh larger degree wave counting
and in the third wave here we are doing
the same thing
as usual guys one two three
four five first wave second wave
it's gonna be something like this
probably so the question we're having
is is this counting for now correct
is there any reason that this could be
wrong
so let's see if we have some bearish
signs on the short term
so for example one of the signal i could
have here that is telling me that this
one two is not good
if is this second wave is too deep so i
measure
this first wave and i apply the fib
retracements guys fig retracements are
very useful for that
they tell you if the bullish case is
still
valid or not if the probability of
seeing this bullish case happening
is decreasing for example above 50
percent
is what we call the bullish zone and
between 50 and 61.8 in the second wave
it all depends on which wave you're
considering but in the second wave
i don't like to see the price action
going below the 1.618
here 165. my bullish case would be
still valid as long as we are developing
above 165 all right and here we already
had our abc
correction
so to me the most likely scenario is
that we
are doing this third wave of the third
wave of the third wave so which is
actually
something that should be very bullish
and we got this we got
this very bullish signals all right even
here guys okay let me check what
happened since the
beginning of the third wave guys this is
you know the wave i'm considering the
blue one here
we had 35 guys up in a matter of
three days so this is a typical third
wave and this is a correction of a third
wave and now we're gonna keep going
higher all right this is my view but
once again if we trade below 165 i would
be
worried something else so let's forget
about this counting for now
something else guys is the 175 level all
right so
173 175 you know something like this i
just connect
the lows that i have here you can see
and here
i have some highs so this level is
actually for me a very important pivot
point
and once again you can see how the price
action reacted to it
we blew right through it doing a very
strong move up why guys we had this
strong move up here
i can tell you it's because some people
they were having stop losses above 175
and this strong move up is actually the
stop losses getting lifted
then here we correct you can see that
the 175 is acting well as support
we just go quickly below but on the
flowers time frame it is not broken it
is intact
as you can see here just a fake breakout
it's not even a fake breakout because we
don't have any confirmation
we closed slightly below all right we
closed at 172.3 guys this is
fine and then right away we go higher i
see only bullish
signals from here once again i may have
some delay when i post this so i hope
that's not going to be a strong bearish
move but i expect the price action to
keep developing higher and to get
rejected around
215 and i'm going to tell you why in my
next video
so guys if you enjoyed this one please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show see you guys